magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman one of the
incredible things that has happened in
the context of the russian invasion of
ukraine is that much of the world has
become united against russia
and in defense of ukraine you look at
the list of countries now sending
military support uh weapon support
rather
to ukraine it's an incredible list and
with some rare exceptions i mean you
know
uh belarus and you know the the typical
handful of exceptions
much of the world has not been as united
for or against anything as we have seen
over the last week and as i've said
before the ukrainian president zielenski
was not particularly popular before this
started and there are still
all sorts of concerns when it comes to
corruption in ukraine as we've talked
about before
but the degree to which he has become
what you know often i say as a joke
defiant and principled but he has
remained defiant and principled in a way
that people the world over are really
rallying behind
and most recently uh with a
quite frankly a viral speech
to european parliament during which
you'll hear the translator
become audibly emotional
leading to a minute-long standing
ovation after the second clip let's take
a listen and this is the voice of the
translator that you will hear
we're
fighting just for our land
and for our freedom
despite the fact
that all life cities of our country are
now blocked
nobody
is going to enter and intervene with our
freedom and country and believe you me
every square
of today no matter what it's called it's
going to be called
as today freedom square
in every city of our country
nobody's gonna break us
we're strong we're ukrainians
and of course um
the hope would be
that indeed
ukraine will be able to repel the
invasion from russia we don't know that
know that yet and if it doesn't happen
it will not be from lack of desire
or resolve it will be because of the
sheer size of the russian military and
uh the most recent uh reports are
that kharkiv is increasingly surrounded
and you know it's so hard to know what
is really going on because you many of
the reports that have come out later are
retracted or were based on confused or
incorrect information
uh but the desire is there and here's
more from the ukrainian president
selenski
ending his speech before european
parliament uh to a minute long standing
ovation so do prove that you are with us
do prove
that
you will not let us go
do prove that you indeed are europeans
and then
life will
win over death and light will win
over darkness glory be to ukraine
[Applause]
so as you can tell uh quite a united
planet at this point in time and there
are as always conflicting reports coming
out of russia
on the one hand when it comes to the
military front like i just said reports
that kharkiv is in an increasingly
precarious situation as of the last
three four hours uh surrounded and that
things are not looking good at the same
time there are multiple reports
that putin's grip so to speak on power
may be starting to slip at least
ideologically yahoo news daily beast
article rather the russian people may be
starting to think putin is insane
and i encourage you i mean listen i
encourage people to read all of the
things that are being written and
understand that what really happened if
we will ever fully know the story it's
only going to be in retrospect but we
will of course
continue covering what is going on
and hope
hope
that indeed ukrainian forces and allies
are going to be able to repeal uh repel
uh this horrifying invasion and we will
continue talking about what the what the
next steps may be and uh quite frankly
joe biden's state of the union address
tonight which we'll be covering live
may give us some of that information in
the meantime there's much more to talk
about here and i want to talk next about
an incredible statement made by the
ukrainian ambassador to the united
nations
for me
joking about suicide is not something
that i do uh on the show
and i am not someone who says here's a
list of topics you can never joke about
but on this program we we do sometimes
joke about things but i don't joke about
suicide
uh and it makes it all the
more um interesting
that the ukrainian ambassador to the
united nations sergey kislytsia
yesterday said in a serious way again
without joking about suicide if putin
wants to end up dead
he should just shoot himself dead the
way hitler did in the bunker in 1945 and
the point here
is actually it's not a joke it's if for
whatever reason putin has a death wish
the desire to destroy
reckless uh
reckless desires which could lead to him
ending up dead
don't kill other people just kill
yourself
and that's me paraphrasing let's listen
to sergey kislytsia yesterday to the
united nations we have been prompted to
call for an emergency special session as
the level of the threat to the global
security has been equated to the to that
of the second world war
or even higher following
putin's order to put an alert russian
nuclear forces what what a madness
if he wants to kill himself
he doesn't need to use nuclear arsenal
he has to do what he say what what the
guy in in berlin did in the bunker
in may
1945. so of course he's referring to
hitler taking his own life and i think
there is a point here that is a good one
if vladimir putin has a death wish if he
wants to blow everything up proverbially
as much as literally and end up dead
potentially he could just take himself
out and not as many other people
i don't think this is a joke about
suicide it's not a question of
encouraging suicide or any of it the
sentiment that comes through here is if
you're determined to ruin your own life
why do you have to ruin so many others
as well i was watching video on
argentinian television this morning
they have correspondence on the border
between ukraine and poland and to see
the looks of shock on people's faces as
they flee ukraine
some literally unable to speak for
periods of time
from the shock that they are
experiencing you you don't have to ruin
other people's lives if you're simply
determined to ruin your own now to some
degree
i would bet anything i have
that the topic of assassinating putin
has come up at the top levels of
government i'm not saying anyone's
thinking of doing it i'm not saying
anyone plans to do it or would do it but
without a doubt
when aids are supposed to present all
options to world leaders
it is impossible to imagine that they
are coming forward and saying okay we
can send weapons we could send troops we
could look at drones we can do this we
can do that
here's what it would look like if we
tried to assassinate putin it's clearly
being mentioned by the people who were
paid to present all options to world
leaders i don't believe it's being
seriously considered i don't believe
it's going to be done and i'm not
suggesting it be done but the point here
from the ukrainian ambassador once again
is
not everybody has to suffer because
putin has become a reckless tyrant and
uh that certainly is coming through in
the desperation
of the voice of the ambassador from
ukraine to the united nations
all right this next topic i've really
been hesitating to do it because it's
completely speculative but sometimes it
becomes so hard to explain behavior in
empirical ways with facts that we have
that it becomes difficult to avoid
speculating so i'm going to say this
super clearly this is speculative
thinking out loud based on the number of
people who have written to me you guys
and said
could vladimir putin be terminally ill
and could that explain his behavior
which is unhinged and seemingly reckless
as well as potentially self-destructive
to himself and to russia vladimir putin
seems to be making uh decisions that
apparently can't end well for him nor
for russia
the economic damage being inflicted on
russia as a result of the the sanctions
in response to putin's aggression
according to some could damage russia
economically for decades
and what many of you are thinking from
the emails i'm getting
is could some horrible illness explain
it one person wrote to me and said
putin's face is pudgy
could he be on steroids for some medical
condition could that be one reason for
his rambling and his increased
aggression it's very vague it's very
speculative another post on the
subreddit uh the david pakman show
subreddit said is putin terminally ill
and that's why consequences
don't matter to him
speculative another aspect to this is
the pictures of putin sitting
cartoonishly far away from people during
recent meetings yesterday i retweeted an
image from the morning of putin meeting
with his supposedly top advisors and he
quite literally appears to be at a
50-foot long table 50 feet away
from his closest advisors
and there's many possible explanations
for that he's generally known to be a
germaphobe it could be that simple we
heard well he's just very careful about
kovid um it could be as we talked about
on yesterday's bonus show
putin may fear
that someone within his advisors might
try to kill him and so he's keeping
physical business i mean it really could
be anything
the other aspect of this that people
have talked about is that in two videos
from last week videos which in principle
were filmed days apart
vladimir putin is wearing the exact same
suit and tie he seems disheveled he
seemed sort of confused leading to
speculation that the videos were filmed
at the same time and putin's not really
well enough to be out and filming videos
regularly again it is completely
speculative and what's going on here is
we're all trying to come up with
explanations
for unexplainable behavior from vladimir
putin is he simply this much of an
unhinged authoritarian and he's not sick
and he's just doing this anyway does he
have a death wish is he such a
narcissist that he thinks he won't end
up hurt no matter what he does or you
know at the tail end of that is is he
terminally ill and just trying to go out
with a bang no one hypothesis is that
much crazier that much more crazy or
that much more likely
one journalist udo lishkeez who's the
former director of the german
broadcaster ards studios in moscow
also brought up the possibility that
putin could be suffering from a serious
health issue said um uh after seeing
these recent videos of putin he just
doesn't look at all like he looked
months ago and lishkey's highlighted
claims
by foreign affairs specialist in
academic fiona hill who said putin could
potentially be ill so
that's the whole story you all now know
everything i know and everything that's
been said
uh i'm curious to hear your thoughts
understanding that i'm this is not a
news report of putin being sick this is
could this be going on many of you seem
to think it is and you've brought it to
me
and
now you basically know all of the claims
that i'm aware of let me know find me on
twitter at d pacman i'm curious to hear
your thoughts
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar that's why
you should check out our long time
sponsor magic spoon magic spoon tastes
exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar
14 grams of protein and only four net
carbs so it's perfect if you're doing
low carb or keto or if like me you just
try to limit your sugar intake you can
build your own variety pack with flavors
like cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman i
am so thrilled that the audio podcast
continues to grow the audio podcast even
though we are not necessarily in a time
where interest in political media is the
highest you you would expect although we
are getting closer to a midterm um our
audio podcast is growing and growing and
growing and i want to welcome everybody
listening who listens daily to the one
hour audio podcast of course available
for free we are a viewer and listener
supported program and i would love for
you to sign up on our website
joinpakman.com you do get a commercial
free version of that podcast or a video
version if you prefer
as well as access to our daily bonus
show as a member you can sign up at
joinpackman.com
i want to talk today about one tool used
by reactionaries to fool people and to
goad people into reactionary beliefs and
that is the use of the fake and or
imaginary slippery slope
in general reactionaries use fear as a
tool they aggrandize threats beyond what
they are to make people afraid
and then they use that fear to try to
get people to support certain policies
if you're really afraid of brown people
from mexico coming to commit crimes and
take your jobs you're likely to support
extreme policies on immigration so the
the use of fear
uh and fear mongering by reactionaries
is very common one example of the false
slippery slope and a slippery slope is
saying well if we do a
it's
definitively going to lead to b c d e f
etc when sometimes a will just be a
and a great example we have because of
the pandemic
is the fake slippery slope of vaccine
mandates as you may know for over a year
now
the reactionary right has been saying
the first thing is you got to get a
covet vaccine and the next thing you
know
abcdefg
and we now have over 200 years of
history to tell us that vaccine mandates
don't lend themselves to more
authoritarianism and you just look at
the history in 1777
george washington required the smallpox
vaccine for all soldiers
and then you know 30 years went by and
in 1809 massachusetts put in its first
vaccine mandate and then another 40
years went by and then in 1855 a
massachusetts massachusetts instituted
vaccine requirements for schools and
then in 1905 in the u.s supreme court
case jacobson v massachusetts the
supreme court said now municipalities
can just can can put in a vaccine
mandate and people are saying this is
the start of what
and it just never went further in 1977
we had the childhood immunization
initiative start and it's just about
getting kids vaccinated and more
recently people with the covet vaccine
saying this is the start of a dystopian
authority
no and in fact many places have already
removed vaccine mandates for travel
employers are removing vaccine mandates
as the pandemic wanes and so it's an
obviously false slippery slope the
vaccine mandates over the last 200 years
have not led to anything more than that
you can really
tell the the difference in how the right
uses
slippery slopes and fear mongering by
thinking about something like healthcare
i mean let's just think it through
we on the left say about healthcare
listen the right wants this like total
for-profit free market health care thing
they generally speaking want to let
insurance companies charge whatever they
want to people with pre-existing
conditions deny them insurance and if
the right got its way we would continue
to see medical bankruptcies which we're
already seeing we would continue to see
people unable to afford or access care
which we already see all of this stuff
exists right now okay there's no crazy
fear-mongering from the left on health
insurance the right says if the left
gets his way
gets its way it's the start of a
communist takeover of health care where
government bureaucrats will create death
panels and decide whether you live or
die and it will be the start of a
government takeover of every industry
what
so you see how one side does the
slippery slope reactionary
fear-mongering and we say we're going to
continue seeing the same problems if we
don't if we don't fix this very
different language that's used
so the best thing when you start hearing
these slippery slope claims if you do
this it's going to lead to all this
other stuff
first of all ask for examples of when
that has happened that's one tool that
you can use
secondly
ask the person claiming the slippery
slope will happen to explain exactly how
because if you actually say to people
well hold on how will a vaccine mandate
on covet vaccines lead to whatever it is
you're afraid of like exactly what are
the steps and who will enact it and it's
also a good tool
to show the disconnect between the
different pieces of the slippery slope
often they won't even explain the path
down the slope
when they do it often makes no sense
whatsoever so those are some tools that
you can use but whenever you're
presented with a slippery slope
ask yourselves those questions is there
historical evidence that that's what
would actually happen
how would it happen and does that
actually make any sense
one of the really interesting things
we're seeing over the last week
has been this reversal from much of the
republican party
about the ukraine russia situation
and early you saw a bunch of
right-wingers including trump tucker
carlson uh tulsi gabbard who claims to
be on the left but we know she's not um
sort of defend vladimir putin and that
did not go super well a lot of
republicans just weren't buying it
because it's completely implausible that
we should be supporting vladimir putin
so now they're sort of switching to
supporting ukraine and one aspect of
this is that now many people who have
been against nato for a while are
switching to talk about how great nato
is and the the sort of most um uh
notable bullet point about this is that
donald trump is now
taking credit for nato's existence even
though for much of his presidency he
wanted to end nato and get the us out of
it and and just completely take it apart
rolling stone uh rolling stone's peter
wade has a good piece of this called
trump who wanted to withdraw the u.s
from nato
now claims credit for its existence
there would be no nato if i didn't act
strongly and swiftly the former
president said he put out this statement
or you know it was put out from by his
new spokes relatively new spokeswoman
liz harrington he put this out yesterday
and the statement reads i hope everyone
is able to remember that it was me i
mean it's literally like a little kid it
was me as president of the united states
that got delinquent nato members to
start paying their dues which amounted
to hundreds of billions of dollars there
would be no nato if i didn't act
strongly and swiftly which is a
laughable claim
nato was very strongly in existence
before trump became president there was
no sign nato was going away trump adding
also i mean he trump did everything good
i guess guys
also it was me that got ukraine the very
effective anti-tank buster javelins when
the previous administration was sending
blankets
let history so note now of course
revisionist history is not unusual when
it comes to donald trump and you need
only go back to an article i mean in
this case from january of 2019
from vanity fair by eric lutz
which reported that donald trump
privately discussed destroying
the nato alliance the president
repeatedly told aides that he wanted to
withdraw the united states from the
alliance the new york times reports
trump islam criticized nato frequently
bellyaching that the military
partnership has been unfair to the u.s
and on and on and on however it appears
trump's attacks on nato are more than
bluster
citing senior administration officials
the new york times reported late monday
again this is january 2019 that at
several points in 2018 trump discussed
withdrawing the u.s from the
international organization a move that
would effectively doom the 29 nation
alliance and empower russia which has
spent years seeking to weaken it so
understand the absurdity of this
trump now is taking credit for nato
because nato is so involved in
supporting ukraine against russia
what trump actually was threatening and
thinking of threatening to do and
thinking about doing during his
presidency was pulling out of nato
altogether which would have crippled it
and of course his people will praise the
flip-flop as the absolute truth and say
everybody else is brainwashed if you
don't accept trump's lies
now remember that this is a common thing
that donald trump does he told people
originally
that the vaccine is something he created
and gets credit for it and of course
that's not true
then he played coy with anti-vaxx
talking about freedom and all these
different things and then his supporters
didn't get the vaccine and then he
flipped again and says well i get credit
for it and his supporters they do both
they it they they see
or maybe they don't accept the absurd
contrast and contradiction in trump's
claims about vaccines and yet they don't
care they still support the guy and it's
very similar when it comes to nato and
it's really important to understand the
degree to which this guy is a liar and
so are his followers not only did trump
constantly attack nato which aligns him
with putin remember putin's one of the
big antagonists of nato and when trump
was president he aligned himself with
the antagonists of nato remember that
trump also froze us aid to ukraine i
mean remember the entire ukraine thing
the impeachment and everything trump
wanted dirt on biden from ukraine
and he initially said we're not giving
them the you the aid
until they get me the dirt now
eventually pressure became so great that
trump did have to release that military
aid and now he wants us to believe he's
always been the big defender of nato and
it's actually thanks to him that nato
even exists we all see through it
but unfortunately
many of his followers don't and that's
what i want to talk about next
there was a new cpac straw poll done
this weekend at cpac
and although donald trump is still
leading the 2024 presidential straw poll
ron desantis is polling higher than ever
before 28
and trump is furious so we we want to
kind of
consider this story
in the right context trump is still
winning the straw poll
but the margin by which he is winning it
for the 2024 republican primary is as
small as it has ever been
the hill reporting trump wins cpac straw
poll as desantis support grows
former president trump emerged as the
clear winner
but
ron desantis is now up to 28
recall as the article does that in last
year's straw poll desantis had 21
support in third place was trump's
former secretary of state mike pompeo
with 2
support
so
trump has been
furious
about what's going on with desantis for
a long time now you might remember that
in november i reported to you trump's
ire grows as desantis's popularity with
republicans takes off and at that point
desantis was only polling between 10 and
20 for the 2024 republican primary
depending which
poll you looked at and what's at issue
here and what trump is so enraged by
is that a number of times now when
desantis has been asked
do you rule out running for president in
general or do you rule out running if
trump runs and desantis has not ruled
out either and why would he when you're
polling 28
and it's years from the election and you
haven't even really talked about running
you genuinely have a good shot at being
the republican nominee desantis would be
crazy if he has any even possibility of
ambitions to be the republican nominee
in 2024 desantis would be crazy to rule
it out so of course he hasn't
and trump's furious
since then trump has gone at desantis
and desantis has also gone after trump
saying things like for example desantis
i don't know that i should have aligned
myself so closely with trump early in
the pandemic might have not been the
right decision
trump going back at desantis the order
doesn't matter but going at each other
saying uh you know he's ungrateful and
he didn't really even do that great of a
job with the pandemic or whatever the
case may be
and one great way to trigger donald
trump
is to not be 100
subservient in every single way
and don ron desantis i've said before i
believe ron desantis is sort of like a
more
dangerous version of donald trump in the
sense that it's the same
wacky
right-wing ism completely disconnected
from reality facts empiricism etc but
desantis is slightly less cartoonish
than trump he's still a cartoon i mean
compared to you know old school
republicans desantis is still a total
cartoon
but he is more competent he's less
obviously clueless and he might be
more able to actually get things done in
the sort of trumpian vein and that makes
him a very dangerous guy so
uh the the prospects for the country are
of course concerning in the sense that
when a governor
with
endless unnecessary coveted deaths is
seeing his popularity take off
that should raise a red flag for all of
us
at the same time we saw 70 million
people vote for the completely
moronic donald trump
who has even more deaths than that on
his hands with his sheer incompetence on
the pandemic and so it's been a serious
problem for a while uh i do think that
one of the best possible scenarios for
the left and for the democratic party
because the left and the democratic
party
are really not
indicating to me
that they have any ability to seriously
win an election unless someone really
helps them out i'm hoping for help from
the republican party for democrats in
2022 and 2024 and one of the best things
i can think of that would happen would
be that trump and desantis get into a
really protracted primary battle and
when we're already talking about 56-28 i
mean trump's still winning but 56-28
this far out from 2024 signals that
desantis really could be a very solid
challenger to trump and i think
democrats have to hope for absolutely
anything they can to help them out
what will ultimately happen i think we
won't know until after the 2022 midterms
and this is again why i continue telling
you guys
in in some way trump seems determined to
run in 2024 even at the cpac speech over
the weekend trump said in the clearest
terms we've heard so far we did it twice
and we're going to do it again in
november of 2024.
i have not heard trump more clearly and
forcefully say i plan to run than that
uh at the same time
i do believe that if the trumpian wing
and trump's endorsees
get crushed in november
i think michael cohen is right remember
when i spoke to michael cohen michael
cohen said he doesn't think trump will
run because trump can't stand losing
again and of course the question is will
trump believe that he can win
or will trump come to realize that he's
destined to lose and on that basis what
will he decide in the immediate the best
thing we can do
is minimize losses in november maximize
wins if there are wins to be had
and foment this
split
between desantis and trump because we
have very little else to be shooting for
right now i i wish it were i wish it
were different but that is the the
reality uh make sure you're following us
on instagram at david pakman show after
this short break i will deliver the
state of the show address and tonight
i'll be live with joe biden's state of
the union address on youtube twitch and
facebook and i hope you'll join me for
that
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
president joe biden is going to brief uh
the country on the state of our union
and today i'm going to brief you about
the state of the david pakman show it's
it's been an incredible year
the second year of the covid pandemic
the first year of joe biden's presidency
economic uncertainty vaccines inflation
other calamities 2021 was an incredibly
strong year from the standpoint of the
show
and i can report to you that the state
of the david pakman show is very very
strong some say the best that we've seen
um in 2021 we added more than 200 000
youtube subscribers not the most we've
ever added in a year but the most we've
ever added in a non-election year uh and
that is now putting us within striking
distance of 1.5
million youtube subscribers our friends
over at the young turks have been really
the standard bearers for left-wing
youtube channels for a very long time
and i can report to you with total peace
and love that in the last few months the
david pakman show youtube channel is
receiving more daily views than the
young turks main channel friendly
competition their network is way bigger
than ours we love everybody over there
but just a reminder with a small team
you can do some pretty amazing things
in terms of the audio podcast monthly
downloads are now at their historic peak
our previous peak was that crazy period
between the november 2020 election and
the trump riots that was our high water
mark we are at a new high water mark now
with the audio podcast
the most downloads a month in the
history of the show
we've got new platforms quickly growing
nearly a hundred thousand followers on
instagram nearly a hundred thousand
followers on tick tock we've launched
youtube shorts content instagram reels
content
2021 also saw the return of the david
pakman show town hall events hugely
popular with our core audience
but
the year was not without some major
challenges
we received the 90-day monetization ban
from facebook after our content was
wrongly flagged for spreading covet
disinformation something we would never
do but it was a big hit to our revenue
thanks to the hard work of
nearly a dozen facebook employees who
are in our audience we were able to get
that monetization ban reversed in under
a month but it's a stark reminder of how
precarious these revenue sources are
more recently we got a 24-hour ban and a
community guidelines strike on tick-tock
due to another false positive in a
segment where we criticized right-wing
actor kevin sorbo and his opinion about
health care we were banned for 24 hours
and now one strike closer
to a permanent ban from tick tock and of
course we were targeted by
right-wing conspiracy theorist alex
jones who launched a brutal attack on my
appearance on my eyes on my face
uh discharged a number of salvos against
our bonus show
so we are up against some major
obstacles uh obstacles in attempting to
move uh towards a sort of more media
literate critically thinking society
donald trump continues to deliver these
erratic febrile screeds on a regular
basis his followers love it fox news
continues to spread disinformation
sometimes spending 24 even 48 hours
talking about
hillary clinton must soon be going to
prison given all the crimes she
supposedly committed just boogeymen
boogeymen of critical race theory
cancellations dr seuss it's pervading
right-wing media and their followers
fall for it
a seemingly on speed don jr regularly
inciting the most bottom-dwelling pond
scum of the political right in these
apoplectic froths
over misunderstandings and distortions
and that's not going to stop
sadly
and it is sad
even some on the left fall for the
disinformation many so-called leftists
wildly attacking me for being a supposed
imperialist bastard despite my constant
refrains that i am against american
intervention abroad in almost all cases
the facts do not matter to too many
people
but
we will not give up and we will continue
to persevere because i see the good
in the independent media audience i see
it in that 15 year old canadian kid who
recently called in inspired so many of
you
with his wit and his intelligence and
his curiosity i see it in the people
emailing me 20 30 40 times every day
even though their emails have been
filtered into the trash for months
they're still enthusiastically emailing
me
i see it even in the right wing troll
callers
who we know
are calling constantly because they see
us having an impact that's why they
won't stop leaving me voice mails
they're worried
that we're talking sense and that people
are understanding it
that's the david pakman show i know
and that's why i can confidently tell
you today the state of the union no the
state of the show is as strong as ever
and it makes me hopeful about the future
of independent media thank you
and god bless
the united fish
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com david
pakman show so some of you might
remember that last week i said to you
jokingly of course when the world is
complicated when i need moral clarity
and when i really need to know what's
taking place geopolitically at such
difficult times i say to myself
what is tulsi gabbard's opinion
now that was a joke but the full joke is
actually i think
what would tulsi gabbard say but what
would televangelist pat robertson also
say and now we know uh pat robertson who
is now 91 years old of 700 club fame
a christian televangelist who has
previously said that so many things are
demonic i'm going to try to go from
memory here pat robertson has previously
said let me think now
yoga
harry potter
ouija boards
sometimes adopted children
sometimes second-hand sweaters
man what else all of these different
things can be demonic and have demons
attached to them so pat robertson
seemingly coming out of retirement to
explain why
russia has invaded ukraine and i have to
tell you
i'm actually actually fascinated by it
um i really find this type of stuff
fascinating because he's completely
created an imaginary world that he i
guess believes exists with
end times and messages from god and
stuff about uh the pharisees or i don't
even know i'm gonna play it for you and
i i wish i had i mean it's almost like a
child-like imagination that the guy has
check this out it is wild
here we go
putin's out of his mind yes maybe so but
at the same time he's propelled by god
he went into the ukraine but that by the
way uh pat robertson still using the
term the ukraine which is just a signal
of uh you know how long he's been
commenting on these things i guess it
wasn't his goal his goal was to move
against israel ultimately
and he will link up with turkey with
azerbaijan i mean with the
across the dardanelles in that little
bridge and they will come together
and then
you look down into
north sudan and you've got a muslim
country down there
and and there they all are persia of
course is iran and there is the land
that is set up in ezekiel 38 right you
see how
ukraine is key because of the you see
the land bridge between bulgaria greece
and turkey
and
all of that area is going to be
mobilized against israel in the latter
days and god says i am going to deal
with it now guys
understand when pat robertson says the
latter days
he's talking about a sort of apocalyptic
rapture end times when he says latter
days he means
the end as he believes to have been
biblically prophesied isn't this stuff
just fascinating so you can look at your
map you can read your newspapers you can
listen to your news but know of a fact
that god is bringing to pass what he
prophesied years ago through his servant
ezekiel now i i always it's always tough
for me to understand
do these christian extremist types
want the end times because
like with some of them from what i
recall and i've interviewed some of them
as well it's just so hard to keep track
of all of it
i think some of them want the end times
because they believe that jesus comes
back then and again correct me if i'm
wrong everybody who's been good gets
eternal life with jesus or something
like they consider the rapture to be
good because the sinners are killed but
you want to usher in the end times i
think even though like most everybody
dies which you and i might be like well
that's bad sir
uh but i think i think people like pat
robertson want the end times
and you read in the 39th 38th passage of
ezekiel 1 through 6. it's all there
and god is getting ready to do something
amazing and that will be fulfilled and
what putin is doing by moving as he is
to set up ukraine as as a
staging ground
for one of the armies and then across is
is erdogan at turkey and and you've got
between them that little dardanelles
area and it's going to happen so i just
say
that is what's coming up is putin crazy
is he mad well perhaps
but god says i'm going to put hooks in
your jaws and i'm going to draw you
into this battle whether you like it or
not and he's being compelled
after the move into the ukraine he's
being compelled to move again to get a
land bridge and then across the
dardanelles with turkey and watch what's
going to happen yeah now um i yeah as
many of you will notice pat robertson is
is not looking great but it still sounds
like the same old pat robertson with
some of those same same ideas so that
that is really wild i have to tell you
there's some weird way
in which i envy people who are able to
be so certain about things for which we
have no evidence and just allow
themselves to be completely absorbed
into that and and it sort of seems like
you don't have a care in the world in
the sense of
it's sort of like with the conspiracy
theorists everything is controlled it's
all predetermined it's all planned it's
just like it's gonna be what it is
there's something about being able to
fall for that that i almost envy because
it seems easier than realizing the
complexity
and uncertainty
of the world that we that we live in and
that hey we actually have an impact here
it's not just like well you know putin
it's all ordained by god putin's gonna
do what he's gonna do and that that's
really it it's been prophesied um as as
a practical matter pat robertson's
predictions aren't very good um and just
as one example here is one where he said
trump's going to win and much like it
was hard to tell whether that last clip
was an endorsement of putin or a
condemnation of putin it's hard to tell
whether this clip is an endorsement of
trump but he was sure trump was going to
win which he didn't of course there's
going to be a war ezekiel 38 is going to
be the next thing by the way isn't he
talking about ezekiel 38 in both clips
then a time of peace
then
maybe the end but nobody knows the day
of the hour when the lord's going to
come back he said the angels don't know
it right and only the father knows it so
i'm not saying this is the second coming
but i am saying there are things that
people have thought would be during a
millennial time with the coming of jesus
that are going to happen in our lifetime
and the next thing is the election was
coming up in just a few weeks right at
which time
according to what i believe the lord
told me the president is going to be
re-elected i'm not i'm saying by all
means get out and vote vote for whoever
you want to vote for right by all means
let your voice be heard but it's going
to lead to civil disobe unrest of great
proportion then a war against israel and
so forth and so on yeah so you know the
israel the
the lord getting back to israel didn't
happen trump didn't get reelected
uh but that is really something and he
has been predicting
end of the world stuff for a really long
time
in 1982
i wasn't even alive yet
he predicted that the judgment on the
world was coming very very soon
in uh 2006 he said the pacific northwest
would be devastated by a tsunami
in 2007
he said mass killings would be unleashed
in america
uh i believe at one point he predicted
an asteroid and that didn't happen
either
uh
but okay i mean that it is what it is
and uh that's pat robertson's
perspective
and even with the trump thing it's like
okay so
is
is it good or bad if the end times come
you can't really tell from how he says
it he's like trump's gonna win and then
there's gonna be unrest and we're gonna
get closer to the end times but do you
like that or do you not like that it's
never totally clear with these guys
here's just the sad clip this really
this really is sad because we've
speculated that the former president you
know the former guy
really doesn't have normal relationships
with people and that includes his own
kids
here is
just another one of these little
segments and it it really is sad eric
trump was speaking at this reawaken
america tour and remember eric trump is
not generally known as the smart one
and uh the reawaken america tour is this
kind of like anti-covert denying
anti-vaxx
religious revival type tour that goes
around the country it's the one where
that so-called comedian jim brewer did
his cockatoo impression that had so many
of the people in the audience in
hysterics
that i didn't find very funny but so
eric trump spoke at one recently and he
did the really cool thing you know
showing the alpha nature of everything
he called his dad trump and he said that
you know he really loves him and trump
said have a good
have a good weekend
um
do you guys feel bad for eric trump but
really for all of trump's kids take a
look
you know what dad there is so much love
in this room for this country and for
you and everything that you accomplished
and uh
i speak on behalf of every single person
here they love you i love you we're
proud of you
and uh just hold your breath everybody
hold your breath
well thank you very much and everybody
enjoy yourselves and have a good weekend
i'll be in ohio soon i'll see you all oh
my god oh my god i mean it's just so
awkward if you've been around truly
narcissistic people
um this is typical of them and this is
typical of how they behave
but as as far as like a parent parenting
thing is concerned you know your kid
says i love you
and you go well thank you very much and
have a nice weekend
it's sad and uh imagine that that's the
one phone call eric's allowed right i
mean we don't know how often eric's
allowed to talk to his dad
um it really gives me kind of like
please love me daddy's sort of vibes and
it is sad it really is sad it doesn't
seem as though trump has a normal
relationship with his kids and it's all
very strange but it is what it is and
there's really not too much more that we
can say about it we have a voicemail
number that number is 2192 david p
i was going to talk to you guys today
about the so let me back up
a week ago i imagined that today i would
be talking to you about the u.s
anti-vaccine mandate trucker convoy
heading to washington dc set to arrive
today
their plan was to get to dc on the day
of joe biden's state of the union
address a week ago i thought i'd be
talking to you about it i'm not because
nobody's paying attention to it and it's
not even clear that
it seems to have sort of disintegrated
and
one aspect of this is brought up in this
voicemail and our voicemail number again
is 2192 david p which is what mandates
are they protesting anyway take a listen
hi david listen i have a question for
you after all the mandates pretty much
been overturned and of course except for
you know by these federal ones in the
service and the airports and stuff
everything else is pretty much an
overturned by the court am i wrong
so why are the current ways still
forming and still trying to make their
way across america now they got bikers
doing it too
and
they have a much further cause why don't
they just take up their guns and go to
ukraine kyle written house to go with
him too he wanted to protect the
storefront let him protect the country
with their patriotism that trump calls
them all patriots but they're true
patriots let it be something patriotic
even if it is for another country at
least it shows they got the ball yeah so
listen a couple thoughts on the u.s
trucker convoy first of all ima and i
tweeted about this yesterday and many of
you wrote back absolutely loving it and
saying you had thought the same thing
imagine that you spend a month or six
weeks or however long it was
organizing this convoy of truckers that
wants to protest vaccine mandates and
government tyranny and authoritarianism
and you're going to drive across the
entire country i don't remember where
they started whether it was california
or arizona somewhere in the southwest or
maybe texas who the hell even knows
they're going to drive to washington dc
and then
quite literally as they're about to
leave to start their convoy russia
invades ukraine and gets 24 7 coverage
and no one pays attention to your stupid
convoy so like that's number one and
that's funny and i genuinely take
pleasure in it that's hilarious nobody's
paying attention to these people because
russia has invaded ukraine but then
there are other layers of absurdity that
are
kafka-esque in this entire thing the
second one is
the whole premise of the trucker convoy
is that these are victims of tyranny and
authoritarianism right we are being
victimized by the tyrannical government
mostly state governments that say hey
you got to be vaccinated against kovid
and
quite literally russia invades ukraine
and people start dying
and the president of ukraine is out
there fighting and you as a trucker are
trying to say i'm a victim of tyranny
when you see what's going on in ukraine
beyond parody okay so that's like the
second layer that's that's funny or you
know curious and then of course the
third one is what the caller is saying
what mandates are you protesting so the
general biden vaccine mandate which by
the way wasn't a mandate because incur
it
include or allowed for a test out option
you can opt out and test instead
um that was blocked by a court
you then have states and municipalities
that have various vaccine requirements
you got to be vaccinated to work in a
healthcare setting or you've got to show
a vaccine card to go to a restaurant or
whatever they're mostly dropping it
because why it was an imaginary slippery
slope all along as covid is waning for
now fortunately and who knows what the
future holds variance spikes resurgence
cases are down 95
and exactly as the same people expected
as the threat from covet goes down
various requirements are being
eliminated there's barely any mask
requirements left yes you've got to wear
masks on airplanes uh there's some some
cities and places that but the mask
requirements are going away the vaccine
requirements are going it's all going
away so what are you even protesting at
this point it's really an example this
entire u.s the canadian convoy was this
but the u.s trucker convoy is even more
so this
what are you protesting at this point
what on earth are you protesting and
they're just desperate for attention
which they're not getting thankfully
not thankfully that russia invaded
ukraine but thankfully as a result of
there being real news in the world
nobody's paying attention to that stupid
convoy and i'm absolutely loving every
minute of it we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today first of all
what would it look like
if ukraine joined the european union how
would it work what would it look like
and
what would be putin's reaction we're
going to talk about ukraine and the eu
on today's bonus show secondly hackers
have been very involved in the russian
invasion of ukraine taking down a number
of prominent russian websites
uh and doing a whole bunch of other
stuff and one of the recent things that
happened is that 120 000 russian
soldiers have been doxed by hackers
meaning that their identities and their
personal information has been released
and
we're going to talk about obviously
that is is not in the realm of what we
typically consider cyber warfare
but where does that type of thing fit in
in
international military conflicts there
are differing opinions it might sound
like no no no here's the here's the one
view on doxing soldiers and its validity
but there are actually some dissenting
views on that we're going to talk about
that and then number three yesterday i
told you that fifa has determined russia
uh russian players can play in the world
cup but no russian national anthem and
they can't be identified as russia
that's been cancelled russia has now
been totally thrown out of the world cup
fifa has decided they're just it's just
a hard no and we're going to talk about
that and other
kind of
sports related sanctions that have come
in the past and that may come in the
future all of those stories and more are
on two days bonus show how do you get
access to the bonus show simple
sign up for a membership at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code please don't war i know it sounds
ungrammatical but that's what it is the
coupon code is please don't war you'll
get a discount off of a membership
you'll get access to the bonus show the
commercial free audio feed the
commercial free video feed and much much
more we will see you then and tonight
live
on youtube twitch and facebook for joe
biden's state of the union address i
hope you'll join me i will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors magic spoon
tastes exactly like your favorite
childhood breakfast cereals but it has
no sugar lots of protein it's keto and
low carb friendly it's delicious without
the guilt get five dollars off when you
click my link below and use the promo
code pacman